تداعيات واعمال الشغب الاخيره لا تزال
تخيم على المشهد الامني في البرازيل فيما
اشعلت وثيقه توريس الازمه في البلاد
التحقيقات بدات تكشف عن تورط شخصيات مهمه
من بينهم اندرس
المسؤول عن الامن في العاصمه البرازيليه
ماء امرت المحكمه العليا باعتقال توريس
بتهمه التقصير في اداء واجبه حتى عثرت
الشرطه الفيدراليه في منزل الرجل على
مشروع مرسوم رئاسي يكشف ادله مثيره للجدل
فماذا فضحت تلك المسوده
تدابير طارئه للانقلاب على نتيجه
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي فاز بها الرئيس
البرازيلي لويس اناسيول ولادا سيلفا تورطه
وزير العدل والامن العام البرازيلي السابق
جرير بور سيناريو باحداث اقتحام المقرات
الحكوميه تحمل بورسنا ومسئوليه تخريب
المؤسسات الحكوميه من قبل انصاره الى جانب
تسهيل عناصر من قوات الامن المواليه
لبورسونارو دخول المخربين الى المؤسسات
الحكوميه
وثيقه تحمل الكثير لكن توريس نفى ما جاء
فيها ونفى ايضا تورطه في اعمال الشغب
الاخيره متهما الشرطه بتسريب محتوى
المسوده عن قصد ومع عوده الامن وان كان
بشكل تدريجي يقول خبراء في القوات المسلحه
والمنتدى البرازيلي للامن ان لولا بحاجه
الى وزير دفاع قوي لمواجهه ايدولوجيه
بورسونارو داخل المقرات الامنيه والقوات
المسلحه وتغييرها بالكامل جاسم محسن
العربيه